for more on all this some analysis let's
go to ian bremmer president and founder
of eurasia group and g zero media ian
good morning to you uh you've got a
reputation for seeing these things
clearly so let's talk as plainly as we
can for the rest of us here
what does it mean for russia to
recognize these independent regions in
ukraine and then cross the border is
that not an invasion
it is an invasion
it is the end of the minsk process
the americans the europeans have
coordinated and saying this was
unacceptable and that sanctions would
result as a consequence uh it is the
failure of the negotiations process that
the americans and our european allies
have been working on assiduously for
months now i also want to say tony very
importantly this is a slap in the face
to the chinese
you'll remember president putin went to
beijing as part of the opening
ceremonies for the olympics and got the
strongest coordinated support from xi
jinping that the russians have received
in the post-cold war era and but the
chinese said explicitly we want the
minsk agreements to be the basis going
forward we want negotiations we
recognize the territorial integrity of
ukraine president putin has just slapped
in the face his most important major
friend on the global stage and we have
not yet heard the chinese respond to his
measures i am exceedingly interested in
what the first statements from the
chinese will reflect
so if you're right he's upsetting the
chinese he's upsetting nato he's
upsetting the biden administration why
is ukraine so important to putin and why
should americans care
well americans should care uh because
we're entering a new cold war with the
russians and they are the major exporter
of gas to europe um you saw that prices
now are at seven year highs that's going
to affect every american at the pump the
russians are a country with basically
offensive cyber capabilities that are
roughly a parody with the united states
you remember when they uh attacked the
colonial pipeline brought a lot of
americans offline and lacking energy
they stopped doing that when biden
warned them for a few months but they've
now called the americans bluffs so cyber
attacks are likely to come again that
really matters to us as well but why are
the russians doing this why do they care
so much about ukraine because putin
believes that the collapse of the soviet
union was the greatest geopolitical
disaster of the 20th century and he's
trying to rebuild it and you will see
that with the new constitution in
belarus on february 28th that will no
longer be neutral it will no longer be
non-nuclear and the russians will likely
establish permanent integration and
bases there you will probably see it in
places like moldova where the breakaway
republic of transnistria right now is
looking to place the same request for
russian recognition that you've seen
from donbass in the last 24 hours and
most importantly 44 million ukrainians
that putin never believed should have
been independent they should have been a
part of the soviet union in russia and
he's trying to rebuild that right now
so ian if the international community
wants to stop all this let's talk about
how you've said diplomacy has failed
let's talk sanctions we just heard this
morning that the chancellor in germany
is halting careful language there this
major pipeline between russia and
germany will that be enough what more
needs to happen on the sanction front
uh look you can't use all of your
sanctions right now because the russians
are not yet in territory that the
ukrainians presently occupy even though
they are directly in ukrainian territory
i think if ukrainians start getting
killed and they roll tanks into
ukrainian territory that the russians
hadn't previously held post 2014 then
you'll see more sanctions from the
united states and europe but to be clear
uh you are going to see more sanctions
from the americans today you already see
that nordstrom 2 is being announced
effectively dead and this is an enormous
project that they've been working on for
years now there'll be some financial
sanctions there'll be some other
sanctions from the americans but putin
has already factored all of that in you
are not going to prevent the russians
from taking further action through
sanctions if there's further action
that's going to be prevented it will
become because either the russians
believe that they can get what they want
through other means and that means
either negotiations or the ukrainians
suing peace or because the chinese
decide to push them hard we will watch
that ian we will watch that uh ian
bremmer we appreciate you cutting it
cutting through the noise for us this
morning thank you very much